(dramatic music)
- I think it's part of
who we are as a species
to ask the question of where are we,
where did we come from,
where are we going,
and are we going there alone?
The largest mirrors in
the world enable a chance
for all of us to answer those questions
that mean so much to us.
(mysterious electronic music)
My name is Patrick McCarthy, and I'm
the principle astronomer behind the
Giant Magellan Telescope project,
the largest telescope in the world,
handcrafted, start to finish, here
at the University of Arizona.
(plucky music)
The process of making
a mirror, in some sense,
it's like making a cake.
First thing is you get
all the ingredients,
you have the glass,
you build the mold and
we put the glass on top,
and then you put it in the oven.
It's then heated up to
such a high temperature
that the glass melts,
until follows into the mold
and makes the rough shape of your cake.
Now in our case the
icing is the hard part.
The mirrors weigh about 17 tons,
they're up to 8.4 meters in diameter.
That's a really big piece of glass.
Then to turn that piece of
glass into a final optic
takes another two to three years of
precision grinding and
polishing and testing.
Each mirror, from start
to finish, takes roughly
seven years to produce and there's roughly
a hundred people working on it.
So about 200 person years go into making
one of these mirrors.
(gentle music)
The Giant Magellan Telescope will be sited
in the Chilean Andes.
You have the sharpest images in Chile,
dry weather, clear skies,
and no artificial lights.
It's a perfect place for astronomy.
The challenge, of course, is how you handle
this beautiful precision piece of glass.
So we lift it with suction cups.
The mirrors are moved very carefully
because they are glass, after all.
Telescopes are our vehicles of discovery,
they're our ships in the universe,
and the heart of the
telescope is the mirror.
It's the thing that collects the light
that's come from millions or
billions of light years away
and brings us that information
that can allow us to
answer those questions,
where did we come from, where
are we going, are we alone?
(mysterious music)
(tone chimes)